okay so the topic of this video today
is the process of dna replication
so let's get started
okay so before we get started on
replication you know here's a
cell and cells tend to grow and they
divide and multiply but oh no look
there's a problem
the cell on the right doesn't have a
piece of dna
on the inside so there has to be a
solution before cells divide
let's make more dna and so here we have
our cell again watch what happens to the
dna in the cell
a copy is created so when the cell then
grows and divides
the two cells each have a copy of the
dna that they can use through their life
so dna replication is how cells obtain a
copy of their dna
needed when we look at dna replication
it's the process of
copying the piece of dna one piece of
dna gets copied into two
and this process takes place during the
s stage of interphase if you're in my
biology class this is something we
learned earlier
in the school year hey by the way here's
five pictures one of these is interface
remember which of these is interphase it
was
uh picture e the cell with
the normal-looking cell the nucleus
intact so that's an interphase picture
and so during the s stage of interphase
is where
dna replication tends to occur
okay i want to mention that dna is a
antiparallel
molecule well here's one strip of
nucleotides
that makes up dna on the left i just
labeled that
five prime on the right i labeled that
three
prime the apostrophe is a symbol for the
word prime and you'll see what this
means
in a moment but let me add the second
strip of nucleotides
and on the right hand side i'm going to
label this 5 prime
and the left hand side i'm going to
label this 3 prime
so dna is a parallel molecule parallel
because the two strands of nucleotides
run alongside one another but it's
anti-parallel
in that they run in opposite directions
the bottom strip the five prime is
uh on the left and the top strip the
five prime is on the right now let's
explore what this means
okay let's go ahead and make sense out
of what the heck is the five
prime and three prime that i talked
about a moment ago
well here are the four nucleotides of
dna
the circles represent the phosphates
the pentagons represents the sugar
molecule
and then the a and the t and the c and
the g represent the nitrogen base
now when we find out the five prime
and the three prime direction of of dna
what we're doing is we're looking at the
sugar and we're counting there is carbon
one
carbon two carbon three carbon four
carbon five the fifth carbon that you
see right there
we call that the five prime carbon and
the third carbon right there
is the three prime carbon every sugar
has
a five prime carbon and a three prime
carbon every sugar on the right look on
the right hand side of the screen
there's a five prime carbon and a three
prime
carbon and look at the last one there's
a five prime carbon
and a three prime carbon so this is what
it means to have the five prime and
three prime it's just the fifth carbon
that makes up the sugar of the dna
so let's go back and look at our
molecule
here's that same picture from a moment
ago i hope it makes a little more sense
now
when we say the bottom strip is pointed
in the five prime
to three prime direction but look at
this the the top
strip of nucleotides it's pointed with
the five prime
end on the right and the three prime end
on the left
so again this just goes to clarify what
we mean by dna being a anti-parallel
molecule the two strips of nucleotides
are arranged in different
directions
okay let's go ahead and get into the act
of dna replication let's talk about an
enzyme by the name of helicase
here is helicase and what it's going to
do it's going to break the bonds in
between every a
and t and c and g watch what happens
notice the bond between the c and the g
were broken by the enzyme dna helicase
as the helicase enzyme continues down
the strip of dna it just continues to
break apart the nucleotides
notice that another g and c were broken
apart
and now notice that an a and t are going
to be broken apart
notice how another a and t are broken
apart
and this creates what's called a
replication fork and
as dna helicase continues down the
replication fork will grow bigger and
bigger and bigger
notice how a dna helicase has broken
apart a c from a g
and now an a from a t
and now another a from a t
and now a c from a g
and now another c from a g so notice how
the replication fork is growing
as dna helicase continues down and in
this case a c from a g
will be broken
so now i want to talk about the next
step in this process on the bottom i'm
going to label this strand
the leading strand and you're going to
see that nucleotides are going to be
continuously added
from the five prime to three prime
direction they're added by an
enzyme by the name of dna polymerase
so like the description says dna
polymerase's job is to bond
new nucleotides a's with t's and c's
with g's look in the animation
notice that there's a g dna polymerase
is reading a g
so in comes a c as dna polymerase works
down
the the the leading strand notice how a
g was bonded now dna polymerase is
reading an a
so in comes a t notice how the
nucleotides are being added
5 prime to 3 prime direction
this happens in the leading strand so as
dna helicase continues to unzip and
break apart the dna
the dna polymerase and the leading
strand will just continue to follow
along
hence the reason why it's continuous the
leading strand is continuous
however the strand on top
i'm going to label this the lagging
strand in this case we're gonna see that
nucleotides they're still added in the
five prime to three prime direction but
you're gonna see it's reversed they're
gonna be added in what is called okazaki
fragments
named after a husband and wife team of
scientists from japan who identified
the role that that these fragments play
so here is the another
dna polymerase and notice how a t was
added
in the five prime to three prime
direction we're going to see that an
a is added as the dna polymerase works
the opposite direction notice how a c is
added
again but the c is added in the 5 prime
to 3 prime direction so on the lagging
strand nucleotides are added in reverse
direction so this creates
what's called a okazaki fragment
so as dna helicase continues to unzip
we're going to see that in the lagging
strand nucleotides are added
in the reverse direction in a series of
what are known as
okazaki fragments
so dna helicase continues to unzip our
molecule of dna
so dna helicase continues to unzip and
break apart
the dna molecule
and so now what we're going to focus on
is the leading strand
notice dna polymerase is reading a g so
in comes a c
continuously being added in the five
prime t three prime direction
dna polymerase is reading a t so n comes
in
a in comes a t
so this is all happening on the leading
strand but on the lagging strand
notice i just added another dna
polymerase it's going to be added
in the reverse direction still in the 5
prime to 3 prime direction
but notice how the five prime three
prime direction is just
facing the opposite way so in comes an a
and comes a t and comes a g
and this is again creates what we call
an okazaki
fragment now what we need to do is we
have these two okazaki fragments
we need to bond them together we need
another
enzyme an enzyme by the name of ligase
here comes a ligase and what it does
is it bonds the sugar phosphate
backbones
on the lagging strand and therefore the
okazaki fragments are bonded together
to make a continuous piece of dna here
so let's continue using dna helicase to
break apart
c's from g's and an a from a t
and a c from a g another c
from a g so focusing on the bottom or
the leading strand
dna polymerase continuously adds
nucleotides in the five prime
to three prime direction again the
continuous adding
is only on the leading strand above
on the lagging strand nucleotides are
added
still in the five prime to three prime
direction but because dna is an
antiparallel molecule
it's it's a one strip is reversed from
the other strip
and so these uh this okazaki fragment
has to be bonded with the others that we
saw
earlier and so in comes the enzyme
called
ligase which helps to bind the sugar
phosphate backbone
of a dna molecule
okay so let's use dna helicase
to unzip a few more nucleotides
so again focusing on the leading strand
on the bottom dna polymerase adds
nucleotides continuously
the continuous adding of nucleotides is
only
on the leading strand let's look above
on the lagging strand
dna polymerase still adds nucleotides in
the five prime to three prime direction
but because dna is an antiparallel
molecule
the directions are reversed here we have
an okazaki fragment
and so we need the enzyme called ligase
to again
help to bond the sugar phosphate
backbone
of a dna molecule together
okay let's go ahead and finish
the separating of the dna molecule
by the enzyme dna helicase
and now that we've separated the dna
fully
we can focus on the leading strand where
continuously dna polymerase adds
nucleotides
in the five prime to three prime
direction again continuously
is the difference between the leading
strand on the bottom
versus the lagging strand on the top
nucleotides are still being added on the
lagging strand
in the five prime to three prime
direction but they're just
add because dna is an antiparallel
molecule
the direction is simply reversed we have
again a
a little larger of an okazaki fragment
than the other ones
but nonetheless we need the enzyme
called ligase to help bond
the sugar phosphate backbone of a dna
molecule together
okay so now that we're finished we can
see that the end result are two
identical copies
of a dna molecule it's also worth
mentioning that dna is an example of a
semi-conservative
molecule each molecule of dna is made
from one strand of
old nucleotides the nucleotides that are
blinking were the old original
nucleotides
and also one strand of new nucleotides
the nucleotides blink and are the newly
added ones
this is what we mean by dna being a
semi-conservative molecule
okay there you guys go the process of
dna replication i hope you found this
video helpful
and thank you for watching